I did a video a couple of days ago about
how to throw a buck to water at someone
I've got a couple complaints about that
mainly about me falling in the pool at
the end couple people complain that my
acting was terrible
it was a couple people claimed that the
push was obviously faked and scripted it
was because anyone who would push
someone into a pool without their
permission
he's an absolute jerk I wouldn't want to
hang around with them but no one picked
up on the real obvious clue it was fake
not even the underwater camera shot that
didn't have a camera in the wider angle
no the reason is if you actually try and
push someone into a pool it doesn't look
like that you push someone into a pool
they're not gonna want to go in priority
one don't go in the pool priority to
keep your head above water so it tends
to be sort of a half stagger and then a
bounce and then they come out dry from
here up you put someone into a pool in
the movies on TV though it looks a
little bit something like this go Hadley
the differences exert retrieving the new
camera I went in back first as low as I
could go as much as I could manage and
going underwater and then you can see
that I actually keep myself under water
my arms are peddling the wrong way
because it looks way more impressive if
I'm underwater for a couple more seconds
but I actually would be anyone sensible
anyone who is actually intending to get
thrown into the water wouldn't stay
under they barely go under at all the
hair might even be entirely dry but
what's going to a pool in television you
need to convince the audience if it's a
big splash that's a big underwater that
send them all the way down in reality as
ever it's not nearly as impressive and
that is something you might not know and
now here are all the other tapes of me
getting pushed into the port
[Music]
you're doing this make sure there's
enough distance between the poster for
again and the edge of the pool
your wafer goes in the next hop
[Music]
so Natalie's